[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله هذا موجز واخبار
الجزيره اظهرت النتائج الاوليه للانتخابات
النصفيه الامريكيه تقدم الجمهوريين على
الديمقراطيين في مجلس النواب وتقاربا
شديدا بين الحزبين في السباقي على مقاعد
مجلس الشيوخ وحصل الجمهوريون على 49 مقعدا
مقابل 48
للديمقراطين ويحتاج كل من الحزبين الى
الظفر بمقعدين على الاقل حتى يتمكن من
الحصول على الاغلبيه
لما يستبعد الرئيس الامريكي
احتفاظ حزبه بالاغلبيه في مجلس النواب رغم
خسارته عدد من المقاعد وفي المؤتمر صحفي
عقده الليله اعرب بيض عن استعداده للعمل
مع الجمهوريين بغض النظر عن نتائج
الانتخابات
امر وزير الدفاع الروسي سردي شوبي سحب
القوات الروسيه من الضفه اليمنى من النهر
دينيترو في خيرسون واقامه خط الدفاع عن
القوات الروسيه على طول الضفه اليسرى
للنار
في الاثنان قال قيد القوات الروسيه في
اوكرانيا ان اكثر من مئه وخمسه عشر الفا
من سكان خرسن غادروا المنطقه طوعا وكان
تصروطات والمواليه لروسيا في المنطقه قد
قالت في وقت سابق انها اجلت نحو 80,000 من
سكان المقاطعه لاسباب الانقلت انها امنيه
نقلت وكاله هوريترز عن مستشار رئاسه
الاوكرانيه ميخائيل بدوليك قوله انهم من
المبكر الحديث عن انسحاب روسي مشيرا الى
وجود قواتنا روسيه في خرسون حتى اللحظه
وقال رجل
اهتماما للتصريحات الروسيه وبان الافعاله
تختلف عن الاقوال
قال السفير الروسي ولا ده واشنطن ناتوليا
انطون الحفاظ على اتصالات مع الولايات
المتحده لمنع تصعيد لا يمكن التنبؤ
بعواقبه امر مهم وتم السفير واشنطن بعدم
اتخاذ اي خطوه للسنه في الحوار بشان
الاستقرار الاستراتيجيه الذين انطلق العام
الماضي كما اتهم الولايات المتحده
بالاسرار على مواصله حرب الاستنزافه ترهق
روسيا واوكرانيا واوروبا على حد وصفه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي حملته من واعتقال في
نابلس وجنين بالضفه الغربيه وعفادت وزاره
الصحه الفلسطينيه باستشهاد شاب برصاص
الاحتلال غرب مدينه جنين ليصبح ثانيا شهيد
فلسطيني خلال 24 ساعه
انها الرئيس الاسرائيلي اسحاقيه سوكر
اليوم الاول من مشاوراته مع ممثليه
الاحزاب الفائزه في الانتخابات بشان
تسميته المرشح لتشكيل الحكومه الجديده يوم
الاحد المقبل واظهر تسجيل صوتيا سربته
وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه ان الرئيس
الاسرائيلي قال خلال المشاورات ان العالم
باسره مفزوع من عضو الكنيسه المتطرف اي
ثمار
السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]